welcome sorry to this rapid game yep two
15-minute game again now is get positive
feedback for those so I'm going to play
one more playing ah Sidorov sidra ja no
name but he's got very high ratings in
been over 2600 in five minute that's
very high there are 15 minute ratings
are always a bit tricky we were you if
you see someone with 2200 you know that
is pretty good but very often those
games are based on not I mean those
ratings are based on not so many games
okay we got the Russell emo Sicilian I
played an early night f6 that's an
that's a line recently suggested in a
book the killer Sicilian bye bye Tony
rotella an interesting book i mentioned
before which features the Sicilian
Kalashnikov variation I how is this
played actually yeah I know that it is
some that is how the line is starting
with Bishop g4 but how does black play
now mm-hmm Knight to d7 i guess i guess
to prepare a 5 i'm not totally sure i
don't want to cheat yeah you can always
if you have an opening book paper you
can just look it up you know where
during the game I'm totally sure that
there are some people who do that
especially in rapid chess 15-minute they
have their books on the shelf and then
they are busy looking up the lines this
is really cheating yeah so not going to
do that so not clear if this is right 97
DS to play e5 and put some yeah get some
foothold in the center if I actually
will play hi if this looks a bit like
yeah position that could arise from from
the Spanish from the rillo passed some
line where he was traded on c6 and the
doubled pawns on c5 and c6 which is
different to see seven and six but but
still it is there is some similarity
okay so what is white going to do now
yeah he mostly has castles or g4g for is
the aggressive way to do it but I'm not
sure about this move it might be M it
might also be just weakening the
appetite and I don't know the theory i'm
just making things up as I go along okay
so this is an interesting move to make
sure that II five can be answered by g4
and I'm losing the e5 pawn however if I
go ecigs mmm interesting up if I go esox
he might have something like we should
terraform
mm okay yeah it's not so easy to develop
yeah if I go if I go f6 intending five
he might play a five himself so that is
not probably not good
Knight b6 civilly 32 33 I guess
yeah maybe I can still play this one and
after Bishop f4 play Knight b6 Bishop f4
night be 693 then f6 may be attending be
5 and possibly after after efore you
have 95 public yeah maybe maybe
something like that yeah this Russell
emo positions with Bishop b5 they tend
to be a strategically complicated quite
often starting with a somewhat close
position like we have here and then it
later gets much sharpen
yeah why definitely also can just castle
I mean that is not a not a bad idea the
only thing that castles would pretty
much give up upon this um the g4 idea
what can also try to Castle long maybe
starting with Bishop f4 now is taking
its time really using the time in the 15
minute format unfortunately it isn't in
non increment format in rapid games I
think it's actually more um yeah it's
even more desirable then in blitz to
have a small increment because the
quality of the play is supposed to be
better but still on at the end you will
have this chaotic seconds against second
situation and very often you you might
spoil almost half an hour of play with
this kind of hectic yeah finishing phase
of the game I like something like 15
minutes and three seconds or something
just a couple of seconds so that you are
able to UM to finish the simple things
okay he's taking his time which is I
mean understandable because it is
complex but but still somewhat
surprising okay at least hear my reply
is simple he decided to take the space
yeah this is something that I am then I
had thought of one idea behind this is
that my bishop on g6 is not the greatest
piece ever quite quite obviously so that
FY might be an idea ok I'm going to take
him to start with if I go Bishop d6 now
he probably plays Knight see form
interesting interesting yeah but should
be six he will play Nancy for other Musa
are completely are very very very
pointless okay how do we do that now
Quincy 7s maybe a month 94 then be five
and ce4 that's an interesting way to
play come on let's do that Bishop f4 I
have Bishop t6 so this is not good at
all f4 Bishop g6 should be should be
really okay for me so night see for some
almost looks almost mandatory and then I
will thinking b5 and ce4 trying to make
some use of the bishop I mean I have the
bishop hair so if my light squared
Bishop is some some more activated that
would be very nice I am ok yeah I
thought Bishop t6 now is good I don't
know what exactly his point is she
taking g6 than 85 but that's not not
really dangerous interesting a knight
move I take a foyer so
he pretty much has to take okay I mean
age takes looks very normal but still
yeah I guess oh and now how does he play
that I am just to just cover them hmm
yeah I interesting and how am I going to
play that space to play some pong break
on structure changing or do I just
castle long come on let's guess along
I'm ahead on the clock and want to try
to keep it like that
against that I can actually give the
check I thought this would be quite
annoying actually isn't it check I mean
he can move the King it's not like this
is impossible
my bishop is not really doing that much
on d6
yeah I just want to be a nuisance here
with the green hair checking his pond b3
Queen a 3m 24 24 c 3 is kind of kind of
embarrassing okay I can go to f6 maybe
this is not such a bad idea but Queen
before I can move the king and this is
really really pointless but on the other
hand what is my queen doing actually I
can go to a 3-4 Bishop see 785 and maybe
maybe that's an idea
and sometimes maybe queen bee to know
okay it's not so clear where he places
where i should place as king maybe just
can you do what I was thinking Bishop
see 785 might be might be an option okay
just attacking g7 oh why not why not
hmm
it's not very comfortable as smooth I
don't know every route g8 looks looks
kind of kind of passive okay that's not
really ideal so I try to get the bishops
traded Bishop c7 a fire I get this get
this done trading of training of the
bishops I should be okay yeah this Queen
a5a 43 venture if this was any good
remains to be seen
yeah at least he's taking quite some
time so that I'm not under huge pressure
on the clock this would be would be even
worse okay I'm trying to get this trade
and now it's not forced or anything he
can he can play Bishop okay yes doesn't
have really have a great square for the
bishop to avoid the trade now we will
see
I get to a five Bishop g5 can be
answered with f6 not quite sure how he
should play him if I get the dark
squared Bishop strated undef initely
okay then it's dark squares will be
really weak and I shouldn't have any
problems at least
maybe something like h4 h5 comes into
consideration try to open up the H file
okay so Bishop 85 if it goes be for
Bishop I even pawn texts okay okay be
sure be 2f queen before threatening
Queen d2
yeah maybe this is still the best
continuation fun hey I should beat we
should probably play Queen before okay
so he wants to do what
Bishop c7 now I get paid by bishop
between okay
now maybe he can play c3 right
yeah no I'm threatening f6 trapping the
bishop Oh difficult difficult position
how what is he playing now actually
don't don't see a really great looking
move have six is very annoying threat g5
on what is this move I can play Bishop
c7 then if I don't really find anything
better may I probably be sure to 70 rout
gave eight no one would give 856 is g7
hanging hmm okay yeah he will definitely
get into time pressure with this this
way of spending his time okay that's the
that's a sharp continuation of course
I did not do not really intend to take
the pawn I was more thinking of Bishop c
70 Bishop b6 bishops e74 the bishop
trade now I guess
my queen on a four is exposed but also
always attacking the h2porn so he cannot
easily coordinate the roxy i cannot move
roxy one or something like that as it
was hanging with a check in yeah they
had to avoid that otherwise I would have
gotten to d4 immediately so r uu k 3 is
not on but I'm take before maybe rook d7
just drooped e74 rock t8 the good
flexible news at least that's what I
hope maybe is be five mo the problem is
really this queen is always attacking a
two so let's say b5 takes rook see one I
will take it to enter I don't think this
is enough that's not enough m yeah so
look d8 for Luke t3 or is this just this
is not sufficient oh my going or should
I play for Bishop t4 really I go look
the eight Bishop g7 rook t3 that's
definitely okay for me rook takes Queen
see to check as an important point
but I can maybe play some other move by
crook the AIDS I know King King
somewhere and then it's not clear that
this d3 business is helping me I'd
really like to trade trade the bishops
on deform there should be six then be
five might become rabid it's not really
it's not really on b5 I can't a cook's
you want shaking b8 check on e5 King a
aid is no attack early i'm still a bit
concerned because of this this Queen
possession which is as mentioned a
couple of times having its points
because i annoy him only to very much
but it also still is somewhat offside
position now I don't see how he can do
anything here while he's not getting any
faster okay so info be viable okay I'm
going to go yet now uh yeah so here
interesting now I cannot take the three
so I'm probably move the King the way
when be five is threatening rooked III
yeah probably bishop to deform maybe but
it's not clear where this is exactly
heading Bishop deform rook moves and
then what exactly
okay the thing about this for a moment
it's definitely a decent enough position
for me but what to do draw our third no
no no I mean I'm better on the clock and
the position is definitely better for
black as well so I definitely don't draw
him maybe f5 I don't know I don't know
exactly
mrs. King is also not very secure so
this is what I'm trying to try to use
okay so rook d4 maybe yeah activating
this and then see what to do with it can
I do look to h4 would be kept attacking
f4 but it's not so easy to get the rook
to h for me okay so he actually allows
me to check on before is there there is
no direct draw back to that I think I
don't I don't see one so queen before or
queen a for Queen a4 again as good
attacking L the week h2porn that cannot
be covered conveniently okay Bishop g4
now Bishop de Foix asks him really what
to do about the porn he has no good
square for you look look T to bishops
III
there's no no tricks right don't see any
okay I can give the check on c2 is this
better than grabbing on a tool somehow I
don't see Jack said so one now probably
just quindi five right free traders
utterly hopeless and how is he avoiding
it okay he traded the Queen's so with
the rook I guess okay so let's let's
March pawns
check yeah the B porn is coming as well
check
white resigns yeah that looked like a
relatively clean game at least on the
surface let's let's go back to them to
the opening stage so he took here and
went I know that this is this is a line
but I don't know how play goes from
there 97 looks fairly logical intending
you five at the right moment the night
is not good on f6 anyway looking at this
protected e4 pawn yeah it's interesting
no he's six maybe this is the way to go
I was thinking Knight b6 maybe but I
mean I don't know this looks a bit a bit
better than than the game because I
think those trades they they definitely
helped me this that's what I thought
here well he he played there for but
German I mean this is I think this is
already very inconvenient this gives
black excellent play using my my bishop
very effectively Bishop f4 we should be
six assists yeah quite clearly okay and
so he went f4 we should be six and now
he has no big choice yes to take Queen a
free can't hear this is I don't know
maybe equium I really don't know I
wasn't sure maybe why does a little bit
better I Scott space and he's got a
pretty healthy structure I don't I don't
really know check yeah I wanted to have
the Queen as an irritating factor I
don't I don't know if this was paying
off Luke g8 it's not a very happy move
but I did
want to play F 60 just cover that and
now this Bishop a5 idea which makes lots
of sense from a strategic point of view
you went here we should be too was also
interesting yeah c3 that sets very
double edged down now as bishop does not
have any squares so he went with before
I don't think really that this is this
is so great but yeah I thought F form
just continuing the whole thing like
here no then then covering in this
situation it's not so clear I'll good my
bishop is
Bishop to c7 may be back I mean this is
I don't know is this about equal maybe a
I don't really see em any problems here
in this position it looks structurally a
bit weak but the double points they are
not really reading this position what
they do is they give me half opened
files which is very important so I don't
know what looks fine and before yeah
it's a strange situation with the Queen
but it makes it makes lots of sense to
disturb him gif you look the computer is
already giving me a very sizable
advantage around T is very unknown yes
in ammonius yeah I know f5 really yeah I
was ok I'm surprised how big the
advantage is according to the computer
stock fishes on minus 2 already almost
one at 1.5 now it's a flipping with the
evaluation it's here we are 1-2
territory here white is just falling
apart and picking up all the pawns yeah
I think probably he should shouldn't
have played this before thing it is
active but it probably is not working
you should probably play c4 and maintain
about equal chances hard to tell but
before was was definitely backfiring
compass even giving f6 here that's
interesting yeah that makes lots of
sense actually trapping the bishop ok my
continuation wasn't bad either but this
is stronger yeah I hope you enjoyed this
rapid game thanks a lot bye